another fruitless visit to Baghdad
Central Criminal Court a bus and without
Sun Ahmed is a tuk-tuk driver and was
detained in February while taking part
in anti-government protests the charges
against my son is that he blocked the
roads he didn't throw petrol bombs he
didn't even carry a mobile he's a
peaceful protester demanding his rights
I don't know why he isn't being released
he has done nothing wrong I just want to
know his fate the judge has twice
refused to release Ahmed on bail but his
parents hoped he would finally walk free
after iraq's newly appointed prime
minister Mustafa Al Queda me promised to
release detained protesters but what was
supposed to be a decisive move to mend
drifts with the protest movement has
turned into a political row Council
announced it would only release
protesters if they had not committed any
crimes but that statement seems to be at
odds with the new prime minister's
orders who said that all demonstrators
should be released except if they were
involved in bloodshed this has led many
to question the Prime Minister's
authority to bring about change it's a
political game the Prime Minister
ordered to release the protesters but
the judiciary's under the control of the
political parties there are powerful
parties controlling the judiciary
according to the Constitution the Prime
Minister has limited power over judges
he can give advice to relieve the
tension on the ground to facilitate the
judiciary processes otherwise if we have
anyone committed any crime or he have
been charged of course he cannot and
from the start we say that if we have
anyone who have been tried already or
charged it needs special amnesty law
adding more confusion the judiciary
issued a statement on Wednesday claiming
that no peaceful protesters are being
detained in Iraq prisons this has led a
bus and we dare to fear even more for
their son's fate they meet a lawyer in
Tahrir Square alongside several other
families
esra Mohammed represents 15 detained
demonstrators none have been released
since Academy's announcement Omar :
they're not complicated cases all of
them are charged under the same articles
which is attacking security forces with
petrol bombs and vandalism the delay in
delivering on his promises risks
undermining the new prime minister's
efforts to win over the public it is
also a sign of the challenges ahead as
he sets out to implement his program
amid a deeply fractured political
landscape semana 14 al Jazeera Baghdad